everyone welcome back to my game 4 recap
video of the gibraltar battle of sexes
chess tournament this one's going to be
a little bit different in the round i
played grandmaster olga giria from
russia
and we had a really interesting game
and then after the game i was
interviewed on the gibraltar chess live
broadcast by international master irena
pomaga
and i asked permission to incorporate
that interview in this video so rather
than the normal recap where i just sit
here analyzing the moves i'm going to
include the clip from yesterday where i
walked through the game with irena and
we had a lot of kind of interesting
discussion interesting analysis
and
after the interview i realized that
there's something really really special
about the game that we played
that i don't want to spoil immediately
so i'll let the
the whole interview play
and then afterwards i will share the
special thing about the game
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back to the battle of the
sexes round four and i've got here uh
eric rosen uh how are you eric
i'm good i'm still cooling down after
the game i just finished like 10 minutes
ago so
still adrenaline kind of rushing through
my system but
good to be here all right and uh
congratulations for your yesterday's win
how did you feel after that i felt good
yeah it was a pretty uh smooth game i
think very instructive game too from the
black side of a nimzo indian
and uh yeah it felt good to like play a
relatively clean game without any
mistakes or blunders uh when was the
last time you won against the gm
oh
um
it happens pretty often
um that's a good question i'm not sure
uh
it's definitely the first grand master
i've been in at least a couple years wow
so congrats on that and let's have a
look at today's game
uh please tell us when did you think was
the first critical moment of the game uh
you could uh yeah sure so i went into
this kind of italian i don't even know
what we call this um this
d4 and e5 line
now i'll admit that i was expecting her
to play carol khan so this was like a
secondary opening that i saw so i had
bets on that you know really yeah laura
said he she
was gonna play the karaoke i went for
the e5
so you had the same feeling as lawrence
did you expected a caracan
yeah well i didn't know what to expect
because she she can play carol khan e4e5
and sicilian so
it's sometimes annoying to prepare
against players like this who can play
so many different things and
um i had to try and just cover all my
bases
so did you have in mind this line when
uh thinking what you'll choose if she
plays e5 before the game yeah yeah i had
this position on my computer screen this
morning
but
during the game i just forgot everything
oh wow because my first time playing
this opening oh really uh yeah i usually
like i usually don't play e4 i'm usually
a london player
um
and uh i figured that this is kind of a
trendy line these days
i think wellesley so has a chanceable
chorus on this line
um and if lock's not prepared then it
can be easy to kind of get a slightly
worse position
um and because she's a carol kahn player
i wanted to test her but it turned out
that i was the one being tested because
she was more prepared than me
so d5 yeah
uh yeah and we got into this position
bishop b6 this is all theory
and then for some reason i couldn't
remember the move order whether i'm
supposed to castle first or knight c3
first no i think you did it you did it
correctly if our memory was so right of
course
yeah yeah like once we reached this
position then the lines kind of came
back to me um but i spent maybe 10
minutes off the clock at this point
and uh yeah we were wondering actually
why you were taking time but now that
you've explained it makes a lot of sense
right
right so yeah thankfully like after i
played queen c2 i i was still in
preparation and uh
the the main line i was more ready for
here is bishop g6 and then queen b3 and
queen b3 97
uh and then castling and it uh then some
bishop d3 bishop d3 eventually and
there's a lot of branches after bishop
d3 but uh okay i would have been happy
to go into that i will uh put it on the
board bishop g6 bishop d3
oh sorry sorry right queen be free first
97
castling c6 so this is like the natural
line
i think i played a game with some knight
d2 here knight d2 is a move yeah uh
getting the bishop hair essentially
um
and
yeah it's one of those things of like
playing a new opening for the first time
like i've basically learned this opening
last like day or two so
uh
it's easy to kind of forget things and
that's why it's it's more important to
just understand what's going on in the
position rather than just trying to
memorize everything definitely but she
took on c3 did it came did it come as a
surprise
a small surprise but i knew this was a
move
and if we go forward a few moves i mean
she was blitzing out everything like she
still had more time than she started
with after f6 takes f6
and i still remember looking at this
position it was either last night or
this morning
um that black can't take on f3 here
because i have the intermediate move f
takes g7 and white's doing well that's a
nice intermetal right right
so instead she went for queen takes f6
queen f6 and i think it's still theory
um yeah i think there were a lot of
games played played in a similar
manner right
and i'll admit after bishop e2 this was
pretty much the end of my preparation
and especially after she played knight
a5
i was on my own
um but thankfully the position kind of
played itself because after knight a5
she's just asking for me to play knight
e5 which i was happy to do
bishop takes c2 then queen e2 c5 are
logical
okay so when she played c5 it looks like
a beginner's mistake because she's
allowed allows knight t7 right and uh
what
what is wrong with it
yeah so uh it's an interesting
calculation exercise because uh at first
it looks like i'm just cleanly winning
an exchange
um but after a few minutes of thinking i
realized that black has queen c6 here
and there's a lot of counter play after
knight f8 and cd4
and the problem is that after say c
takes d4 there is a check coming here
and the rook on a1 is going to get lost
and it's weird like after cd4 i'm i'm
temporarily up a full rook
but i didn't see a good way to
just consolidate and be up material so
i wanted to do this you have to you have
to give up one of the pieces either the
bishop on e3 now or the knight on f8 and
that's gonna be just an exchange up
right
yeah but it's not easy to
beat up the exchange here
exactly
if i take on d4 there's bishop d4 and uh
and even rookie it's now a threat
yeah and
i didn't get in trouble here no white
might already be losing yeah um so i
just avoided all of that
and uh castle short castle yeah
and then we kept going uh cd4
and yeah a lot of these moves were very
natural queen e6 now avoiding knight t7
and queen's very useful on e6 because it
supports this knight c4 idea right
um so when i had f4
knight c4 yeah i really liked this
knight c4 move we were not sure how to
evaluate this position because it seems
like you have a bit of a problem on the
light squares right
right uh especially with my pawns on
dark squares and having dark bishop and
i'm tied down to d4
the move i really wanted to play is g4
and get a setup with g4 f5 and start
attacking
um so i i want to play g4 and you wanted
to make it work right right the problem
with g4 immediately is
i believe
uh what was it i think knight takes e5
and i want to take with the d pawn but
then d4 and i'm i'm getting hurt yeah
the point on f4 will be followed because
especially
yeah yeah
right so you chose to consolidate first
one yeah
proving my worst place piece
and
then
here we got a bit worried about this g4
to be honest
we were afraid your king will be too
exposed actually
but
you handled it well it seemed to us now
yeah i think g4 is called for in the
position even though i am
leaving my king my king a bit naked on
g1
uh i do have the the kingside majority
so it makes sense to push the pawns and
if i get an f5 then there's f6 potential
i thought black has to be very careful
here
but she found uh she found a very
concrete line knight takes e5 de5 and
rook c4 it's a very important move now
because now you don't uh don't have time
to make f5 happen now
right so my dream is to
play f5 and then e6 yeah and i call this
connect four with the
but there's no time to do it because
when i play f5 and e5 hangs and um here
i had to be really careful not to
have my pawns just crumble yeah
so you took on v6 we trade and yeah this
was
quite uh quite concrete after queen b6
king g2
i lose f4
but i win d5
and
yeah i was i spent some time here
because there's queen d2 as well
yeah we saw we tried to make e6 work but
it didn't
i didn't consider
e6
we thought to try a queen sacrifice but
it doesn't work unfortunately so queen
d2 you thought right so queen d2 yeah
and i thought
that uh
at first i thought this should be the
strongest move because i hit the rook i
can take on d5 with chuck but then she
has rook f7
saving the rook avoiding the check on d5
and when i take on d5 there's queen f2
king h1 and queen g3
and at least there will be a perpetual
right well i thought like i didn't see
how to survive in this position
well now there's queen h3 queen yeah
yeah ah right so rook f1 doesn't work
because the rook is hanging right
yeah good point
uh all right um so i spent a long time
trying to see how i could survive after
queen g3 but uh
[Music]
i i didn't see anything clear-cut so i
decided to just not enter this line yeah
perhaps it was for better right
right um but okay after i play rook
takes d5 it's still a little bit
unsettling
because queen c6 i'm pinned
had to play queen d3
and then she found interesting move rook
f8
uh yeah we were trying to make uh rook
c4 work i'm going for some rook city
free ideas so here there is a funny line
i can play queen f3
oh quinn free breaking the pin and after
rook c2
i can play king g3
and then after rook c3
looks like i'm losing a queen but i'm
just meaning
yeah that's a funny line yeah
all right she played druka fate instead
so rook f8 and
uh
yeah and then i'm still under pressure
because rookie it's a threat yeah i had
to
walk my king up
and then she played queen c1
and it looks really scary given that
there's all these checks on the back
rank
um
and yeah there's queen e1 queen g one to
worry about i can't really easily stop
everything
but i realize that i can allow
black to play queen g1 so i play queen
d2 here
yeah that seems like a very good move
because you cover basically all the dark
squares now right except g1 except so if
queen g1 here
i just tuck my king away on h4
right and then black doesn't have a
great follow-up i don't think yeah we we
also thought so because even rook d8
might be possible as after queen f2 you
will have some even king g5
and then you are fine because you cover
the f6 square right
yeah my uh my pieces are well placed
enough where black can't hurt me too
much
but she played queen a3 queen a3 and
then
this just led to a repetition of moves i
played rook d3
queen c5 rook d5
and i still allow queen g1 if she wants
it but if she didn't play queen g1 in
the first position i think didn't think
she would play it again
and
yeah we repeated here
so
i think it was a relatively peaceful
game
yeah it definitely looked like you both
were trying to find chances but
both of you played well so i guess that
draw is a fair result
i think so yeah um i'm really curious to
check the opening theory and also check
with the engine to see if there or
anything missed in this game i am
curious to ask you how how do you feel
when you know there are so many
supporters cheering for you does it uh
motivate you to go for even more than
you would normally yeah it's definitely
motivating um and i definitely
like one of my goals this tournament is
to play really interesting and fighting
chess
and um
i think it allows me to kind of detach
myself
from the results
now it's easy to just focus on just
trying to win or trying to play solidly
but
for me i'm just trying to have
interesting games and
destructive games too well that's a
that's a really nice strategy i believe
and i wish you luck with that before
letting you go i have one more question
sure i saw that you are great friends
with irene sukhandar right and you are
gonna play in this tournament eventually
against each other the final round
actually oh wow in the final round i did
not know that so uh how how are you
trying to
make mindset for that how is it to play
against friends generally yeah so we
were actually teammates at webster
university uh back from back in 2015
through 2017
and uh yeah it's always tricky playing a
former teammate because we we train
together we know each other's
repertoires right and uh i mean for me
i'm just trying to take it one game at a
time so i'm not looking too far ahead at
my my future opponents um even taking it
one move at a time so
uh yeah i'll worry about it when the day
comes but uh for now i'm just trying to
play good moves sure
and you had a very nice comeback as a
team yesterday winning with a very high
margin plus four
congrats on that thank you and what are
your thoughts now about the situation in
the match
uh yeah i've i didn't have a chance
really to look at the other games going
on this round because i just so focused
on my own game
and uh it's a tricky thing about team
chess because of course you
you want to be rooting for your team you
want to keep an eye on the team's games
but
in the end chess is still an individual
game and really i'm trying to do my own
job and then
play
play
to the best of my ability
so um
i i hope that we can score another uh
another plus score in this round
but uh yeah it's nice when
when there is a team to kind of lift you
up especially if uh if i have a bad game
or bad result it's nice when the team so
your team spirit is nice here do you do
you have team meetings do you have
any secret meetings for settling up a
strategy for the next game yeah i don't
want to reveal too many secrets
we do have a whatsapp group where we we
share some secrets
all right thank you very much thank you
uh and i wish you best of luck in the
next games thanks so much appreciate it
all right first of all thanks for making
it this far i appreciate you watching
the whole thing through
except to those of you who maybe skipped
until this point but i'll forgive you
so i do want to share the special thing
about this game
it turns out that according to leech us
this was a near perfect game
if we look at the computer
analysis
uh neither of us made any inaccuracies
mistakes or blunders throughout the game
a very clean game
maybe there are some moments where
there's a very small edge for white
but overall yeah i was i was actually
surprised to see this because there are
a lot of uh of complicated and funny
lines to navigate through
but it feels good to play a really
accurate game this might be the most
accurate game i've ever played in my
life so
hopefully it's a sign of things to come
and uh and yeah i hope you enjoyed the
game if you have questions as usual
leave them in the comments
feel free to like and subscribe it does
help the channel grow
and uh and i do encourage you to tune
into live broadcast it will start at
2 p.m london time 3 p.m gibraltar time 8
a.m central time in the us
youtube.com chess
and i encourage you not only to watch my
game but the whole event in general
there's some really exciting games the
format is really exciting uh currently
the match is a one point difference
between men and women the women are
leading so hopefully we will amount to
come back today so stay tuned and i look
forward to seeing you in the next video